عام منذ ان حرك الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين قوه بلاده باتجاه جارته اوكرانيا
عام برزت فيه سيناريوهات عده لحاضر
ومستقبل هذه الحرب
السيناريو الاسوا والمخاوف الاكبر غربيا
هي الحرب النوويه فما هي اتجاهات روسيا في
عامها الثاني
موسكو من جهه اكدت انها لن تستخدم اسلحه
نوويه الا لحمايه امنها القومي من اي
تهديد وجودي
اما الغرب وعلى راسهم الولايات المتحده
فاخذت تلك التهديدات على محمل الجد محذره
من ان البشريه تواجه للمره الاولى منذ
قرابه خمسه عقود خطر نهايه العالم
مع انه لم تظهر مؤشرات الى تعبئه نوويه
الروسيه الا ان روسيا صاعدت عسكريا
وسياسيا ولجات لاستخدام اسلحه فتاكه في
معركتها باوكرانيا الا ان هذه الاسلحه لم
تضمن لها مكاسب سريعه او انتصارا كبيرا
وهو ما يعزوه محللون عسكريون الى استخدام
روسيا اسلحه عفا عنها الزمن مقابل دعم
غربي كبير لاوكرانيا باسلحه ذات قدرات
عاليه
وعند التهديد بالنووي اصطدمت روسيا بواقع
انها ليست وحدها من يمتلك السلاح النووي
في المقابل حلف الناتو الداعم الاول
لاوكرانيا يملك ذات الاسلحه
كلما تراجعت انتصارات روسيا في ساحه
المعركه لوحت باستخدام النووي لكنه تهديد
لم ينفذ حتى الان
تلويح تم رفضه ليس فقط من اعداء روسيا
وحدهم بل حتى من حلفائها مثل الصين والهند
لكن هل تبقي موسكو خطتها وتكتيكاتها
الحربيه على الارض كما هي ام ان تحريك
روسيا اسطولا بقدرات نوويه لاول مره منذ
الحرب البارده مؤشر قوي على منحنى جديد قد
تشهده السنه الثانيه للعمليه العسكريه
الروسيه روان حمزه العربيه